[inaudible] joining me today is the man that I have dubbed the Willy Wonka of
politics.
It even says so on the back of his book right here.
Michael Malice.
Welcome back to the Ruben report.
Get to be back again.
Dave,
we have a lot to do,
my friend.
Uh,
now most of it obviously is going to have to deal with your choice of wardrobe
at general persona and being,
you've really done it this time.
If I read this jacket,
pendant,
this is the actually the same thing that Johnny Depp War,
but it's a w for him and that's an m and now it's an m for Michael.
Although if you flipped it upside down,
it would be a w for William or Willy Wonka.
There you go.
Uh,
that's actually the,
the one that I didn't see that one.
It's not that either one.
What it is,
it is the better one.
Yeah.
So you're going to tell me the Charlie and the chocolate factory with Johnny
Depp is better than Willy Wonka and the chocolate factory with gene wilder.
And I'm not trying to be a contrarian and I'm trying to block it.
If it's much better.
I haven't seen it,
but there's no way it's better.
Well,
it's pretty good.
I'm telling you how could it possibly be better?
You're telling me he was better.
He was better than gene wilder.
That's what you're telling me.
I'm in a position to make this call,
I suppose at some level because of the great honor that I've bestowed upon you
by calling and either Willy Wonka go out,
but I just,
I mean,
I just don't think anything could possibly be better than gene wilder as Willy
Wonka.
Watch it and tweet out the answer.
This is a really disturbing start to this thing.
Okay,
so let's do this.
So first off,
I'm going to do this interview completely in a different way than I've ever done
before,
which is that you may notice I have no notes here.
Now my policy is that when it's a good interview,
I don't have to look down once,
but I thought,
you're so bananas.
Your political theories are so out there.
I thought I'm just going to sit down and completely see what happens.
I am literally not going to write down one thing beforehand.
Uh,
so the reason that I call you the Willy Wonka of politics,
he's not just because of your,
uh,
high fashion style.
Yeah.
Uh,
but you actually do strike me as a unique political thinker,
which is pretty freaking rare these days.
That's a huge compliment.
Thank you.
That's all I have for you.
Okay.
Good shot.
Let's got to know.
All right.
So,
but,
but you really do.
And even the way you tweet,
the way you use trolling,
um,
you know,
you're,
you're out there,
political thoughts,
all of those things.
I mean,
the way you present yourself,
it's all like just this really bizarre package.
So for people that didn't see our first interview,
just give me Michael Malice one o one.
Let's just get the history out of the way and then we'll,
then we'll go into the new right.
And the topics of the day,
the Glib answer,
he sees the ball.
You hate to love.
Uh,
the longer answer is,
my background is with North Korea was my last book with your reader.
The New Right happen as a consequence of so many of my friends who were in to a
trolls who are anarchists fell down these rabbit holes of what they were,
what was called at the time and he and reaction and later became like the
outright and dark enlightenment.
So I watched the scene from build up from
the ground floor and then to have it culminate to some extent in the Trump
presidency and contemporary cultural wars.
I had a bird's eye view so I knew someone was going to have to write a book
about the subculture.
And I also knew that you know,
any reporter is not going to be able to understand the scene cause at the very
least they're going to be an outsider secondary,
they're going to have their own prejudices.
So since my job had been to make North Korea,
you know,
before I started,
when North Korea work,
the idea was they're crazy and crazy means I don't understand you.
It does.
It can mean,
I don't understand your can mean that your random,
but now everyone understands North Korea is not crazy.
They have a very coherent logical approach to their evil dictatorship.
And the same thing with this scene.
Everyone would like to dismiss it.
Jump ever.
Just loved everybody in.
They're all nuts.
They're all Nazis.
And it'd be really convenient if you could paint everyone with the same brush.
They'd be a lot less efficacious.
A,
it'll be a lot easier to dismiss.
But that's not the way it is.
And people understand that any subculture,
even the,
you know for the Republicans,
they think,
oh the less the same,
the Hillary Clinton hate the Bernie people,
they really hate them.
So there's a lot of different groups in what I call the new right.
And often though they're United in what they regard as their oppositions possess
for progressivism between them,
they do not have much agreement.
Okay.
So with that as the backdrop to all of this,
and this also explains why when buzzfeed and Huff Po and vox and the rest of
them are writing about you guys,
whatever that collective things here,
they always get it all sort of wrong because as you said,
they're not part of it.
So they just look at the,
Oh,
they must be racist.
Well,
they also have an agenda.
Yeah.
So racist means that which is against progressivism.
And I have a list in the books of things that have been called racist,
which includes moving into minority neighborhoods and moving out am I never did
in our neighborhoods.
Noticing races and not noticing races.
Milk a certain time of dinosaurs.
I mean picnics.
Wait,
what type of dinosaurs?
Racist.
Uh,
there was the,
in Jurassic Park,
one of the dinosaurs was called racist.
Uh,
I'm not sure exactly why I didn't follow up meeting through the article.
Yeah.
So I dunno.
Um,
and possibly a,
um,
what's that?
What's his name?
Fred Flintstones.
Pet.
Oh,
Dino.
Yeah,
he's a bit of a white supremacist.
Just,
just [inaudible].
It's unfortunate.
Um,
so I thought someone has to write this book.
And also it's a dark space.
So I wanted to have people be able to explore it in an interesting way and in a
nonthreatening way.
Okay.
So for people that know nothing about this and the couple groups that you just
mentioned,
they are dark and light and mint,
the troll community,
all of this stuff.
Can you just kind of break down all of it?
How did this start?
How did you even start caring about it?
Were you part of it?
What the Hell is going on?
I was on,
cause even for me,
and I have some basic understanding of this stuff,
I'm actually not totally clear on all the sort of markers and where everybody is
online and all that.
So it starts,
I grounded in,
uh,
1992 when Pat Buchanan who is regarded as a paleo conservative,
we teamed up with Marie Rothbart who was regarded as a Paleo Libertarian.
So between those two men,
you basically have everything that is happening today within this scene.
Meaning nationalism,
a trolling,
flirting with racism,
um,
you know,
contempt for authority,
skepticism toward the establishment.
The two of them had many disagreements and at what point,
you know,
Pat Buchanan and turned on Murray Rothbard and later he asked Murray Rothbard's,
um,
executor for forgiveness,
literally,
um,
getting on his knees and asked me for forgiveness.
I broke that news in the book.
And that has come down to contemporary terms where the Internet with social
media allows,
and this is both a positive and a negative,
is back in the day,
if you were that one person in your town with these rude fringe views,
you're the freak.
But now that one person with their weird fringe views in that town can talk to
the other person with the rouge printer using the other town or in Denmark or in
Asia,
or can put on a purple jacket and show up at the Rubin report.
It's all very busy.
They can't pull it off.
Um,
uh,
you have to earn this jacket.
So,
but now they have a community and discussion and they can develop an ideology.
So what I saw happening as a result of hanging out with the trolls is people
falling into this group called what was called at the time near reaction or the
dark enlightenment.
And it was things like we need to return to monarchy.
Uh,
America is this decadent Weimer Republic that's on the verge of destruction and
where was this happening on the Internet?
So I'll need to know.
I know,
but like where,
what do you mean w forums chat exactly for him through all these blogs.
You know,
it's very HP Lovecraft things you're not supposed to know.
It's especially,
it was,
it was blogs,
uh,
not really Twitter at the time and Facebook groups.
Those are the big ones back then.
So this would have been about like 2013,
2012.
Okay.
So now some of this stuff starts bubbling up,
right?
And you start seeing these communities that sort of don't really align but have
some weird touchpoints.
And what do you make of those touch and,
well,
what I knew from my,
you know,
I'm a big pop culture person obviously,
and I knew how culture develops,
which is it starts at the fringe with the Weirdos and then the edgy people,
the cool people like,
hey,
have you heard about this thing?
Then it becomes more mainstream and then like kind of the nerds get it.
Then the corporations appropriated and kind of tone it down,
right?
So all of the intellectual momentum I saw on the right was a result of this
stuff.
These are the people talking ideas,
both nefariously and positively.
These are the ones asking the big questions and basically the radical questions.
And one of the big differences between conservatives than you,
right is this conservatives take what is given and this isn't a slight against
conservatives and regarded as all right,
basically what we have,
how do we fix it?
Then you write often has a more radical approach.
Meaning just because something exists doesn't mean it can't be destroyed
completely and started from scratch.
So these are two different approaches and we see it regarding the press.
I got into an argument with Sean Davis who writes for the federalists.
And his whole point is that,
you know,
the media,
they're all there.
They're all dumb.
And my point is none of these people are very,
very bright.
And if they're all making the same mistake in the same exact way,
that is not a function as to petty stupid people are all going to agree this is
a function of something more nefarious.
So that,
so it's not a bug,
it's a feature.
Correct.
Because they're,
they do have a certain specific agenda and everyone has a certain specific
agenda.
So this is a big separation between conserves and you're right,
is this a,
uh,
you know,
part of society salvageable or is it inherently,
uh,
impure and,
and beyond redemption?
So when Trump was being elected ahead,
Eric Weinstein sitting in that seat,
and what I said to him was,
what most people seem to want is a panther in a China shop.
We know something's wrong with the system,
but we don't want to blow up the system.
We want a panther to walk in there and knock something off with its tail.
And Bang one thing off with the Ted,
but then closed the door behind it and we'll,
you know,
a couple things we'll have broken,
but we'll be okay.
But there's no such metaphor as a,
a panther to try and copy.
It's a bull in a China shop,
but you just can't get it.
I sense that a lot of what you're talking about is these people want the bull
in the chain.
No,
these people want a bomb in a touch on the shop.
They want the China shop to be destroyed.
And the phrase China shop is pretty apps here because it's talking about foreign
influence in America and that's China's not their big villain specifically.
But basically the idea like this store needs to be torn down.
We're not breaking some dishes this we're way past the point of breaking stuff,
but they want to blow up the whole store to [inaudible].
It's not just about breaking the China that's in the store.
They actually want the entire structure and to change
and salted the earth.
Yeah.
To make sure nothing can be built there again.
But so,
so where,
where do you fall on that?
Because I sense there is this weird thing of there's this weird thing on both
the left and the right,
the left seems to really want to destroy the whole thing too in a weird way.
But then you're,
you're talking about people on the new right that want to destroy the whole
thing.
They wanted to destroy it for different reasons.
But what do you think the left wants to destroy?
The left wants to destroy capitalism and they want to destroy the basic way our
democracy has functioned and things like that.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't know that they want to destroy capitalists.
And what should they think of it as something that can milk and harness?
Um,
Bernie,
even Bernie,
you know,
has said,
vaguely positive things to say about capitalism,
but,
and I don't know that they would ever admit.
Well,
I think it's a slow,
it's a slow slope to get there.
You don't just come out with day one and say you want to destroy capitalism.
You just keep right.
But undermining it over election after.
I agree with you,
but what I'm saying is then you write is saying,
yes,
we want to destroy this chapter for this book is called the case against
democracy.
So in the scene there is a huge question of how is it that democracy is
inherently good,
let alone inherently legitimate.
So lay out a case.
Sure.
So the base,
the,
you know,
people say that communism works in theory,
not in practice,
right?
Well that doesn't mean anything because everything works in theory.
You know,
theory means he practices how you figure out something actually works.
Democracy is one of the few things that doesn't even work in theory.
And here's why.
If you have with,
they talk about voter turnout being a good thing,
well at what point does it become legitimate?
If 70% of people vote,
they can speak for the 30% who don't vote.
What if it's 40% vote in 60%?
Don't at what point it that you can say,
this group of the population can dominate this other group,
uh,
who haven't voted.
That's one example.
But even more technical terms,
the purest,
I use an example from this book called the Machiavellians,
uh,
exemplar of democracies.
The town hall,
you have a bunch of people,
everyone's there to kind of speak their mind,
put their point of view across.
Even in the town hall,
you're going to have to have limits on time.
You're gonna have an agenda,
what issues we're going to discuss.
So even in the most democratic system a moment,
you're going to have an elite setting the rules and boundaries.
So one of the ideas behind the new right is this theory of this old school
theory a hundred years ago called the circulation.
The elites,
meaning Hillary Clinton will always have more in common with George W.
Bush,
then she will have with the janitor,
and you can't get rid of an elite.
So much is replace it with another elite
[inaudible].
So this is a little bit of the way game of Thrones ended,
sort of.
I,
I'm not,
I'm not
right.
Okay.
There's a funny moment at the end where they're trying to figure out how to rule
and in the future,
and one of the guys says,
well,
what about democracy?
Let the people vote.
And then there's a moment where you're like,
oh,
where are they going to end with democracy?
And then everyone laughs.
Yeah.
Well isn't there was another new right moment early on because didn't some
person hold up like a PCP,
a piece of paper that says you promised them they basically ripped in left.
Right?
So this idea that the constitution is somehow going to start working and save us
is another thing that they're very skeptical of.
So what,
what are you politically,
if you had to give yourself
I am label.
Sure.
I'm an anarchist or that adjectives.
An anarchist without adjective.
Yes,
sir.
Explain the adjective part of me.
There's different schools of anarchism.
Yeah.
Um,
and I am more,
uh,
there's an arco capitalism this and [inaudible] and Arco.
Communism.
I like it all.
My point is essentially is that government is not legitimate.
It cannot be made legitimate.
And you have to start with that recognition.
Now,
some people think,
okay,
if you take away government,
everyone's going to be equal.
You're going to have wage equality.
Some people think,
okay,
it's going to be hyper capitalistic.
Sure.
I'm a lot more comfortable defending anarchy than I am defending capitalism or
communism or cynical.
Yeah.
Awesome.
So I think most people here anarchist and they just think,
well I mean I say this all the time,
it's just you want to end up in Mad Max.
You just want sort of warring factions,
constantly trying to take each other out and that there is no sort of social
cohesion.
There's no way to build big projects and things like that because we don't have
something that sort of bringing us all together that the government kind of
sucky.
I mean a lot of people think this is kind of Sucky,
but it's the best we got.
It's the best criticism [inaudible] are actually descriptions of the status quo.
Meaning what you're describing is the status quo.
You have governments who are trying to take each other out.
China has,
you know,
hacked our systems.
Russia,
you know,
is interfering in our election.
So other right now nations have a state of anarchy with regard to each other to
some extent.
Um,
what Anik is and would do it provide more security because you wouldn't have to
have a government monopoly.
Uh,
the idea that you need the government to kind of build a big project is really
not necessarily true.
Uh,
and if anything the government is probably the biggest hindrance towards people
working together because they have to run things through some bureaucrat who has
no accountability.
Okay.
But wait,
want,
I want to back up before we go to down that road.
So just break down in a couple of these other groups that were sort of in this
trolling community.
And can you just explain like free for someone of a certain age that really
doesn't even under,
that's not on Twitter and then not on four Chan or wherever the hell is going on
or discord.
Sure.
Like what is actually going on with the trolls?
Like what is the goal of the,
the older people actually know trolling quite well.
Cause the example I use in the book,
the first trial was Andy Kaufman.
So Andy Kaufman,
right?
He was the great troll of all gray trial of all time.
He was on taxi as Laca,
which is not what he's proud of stuff.
And he would do things like,
he had this character called Tony Clifton,
who was basically,
it's like old lounge singer and a pink salmon blazer.
And he'd come down and sing terribly and just be rate the audience.
And,
and one most trolling moment is he had this,
he was performing,
I think in Atlantic city.
And he says,
oh,
well,
you know,
my wife died a few years ago.
And when I look at my daughter's eyes,
I see my wife come on out here,
honey.
And she sits on his lap and they sing and her voice cracks any slaps her across
the face.
And it goes with all you're doing,
or I'm part of the audience is booing.
And he goes,
oh,
don't go.
You're just making her cry more.
Well,
not only was in his daughter,
it wasn't even a child who is an actress.
So trolling correctly is forcing a party,
exploiting a party's weaknesses in order to turn them into an unwitting
performer.
So other examples of this,
there was a little kid,
it's a little autistic kid,
was on the late show in the UK or Ireland and they asked him,
Hey,
what do you want to do Huey Huey,
what do you want to do when you grow up?
And he goes,
um,
I want to fly planes into buildings.
And the guy goes,
what?
He goes,
I want to fly planes,
the skyscrapers.
And he's like,
okay,
if you can't do that,
what would you want to do?
I'll move to Iraq and be a terrorist.
Now it's this little 10 year old boy and the host now doesn't know what to do.
I think he's put on the spot that is trolling.
Now trolling is often used on the internet to be like being a jerk.
That's not,
to me a definition of trolling.
There's plenty of words for that and just go into the cell and saying,
you know,
you're this or you're that.
That's not clever.
Trolling is an art.
So troll.
Okay,
so how is it the Trump understood this?
Do you think that's because this is where people say,
well,
he's just an idiot.
He just says whatever.
Free lunch.
There's no filter that [inaudible] and it's like,
if that really is the truth,
then everyone else must be hyper idiots.
You know what I mean?
I just
can't accept plausible truth,
which perhaps,
let me give a great example of Trump trolling.
Okay.
Again,
trolling,
meaning you're forcing someone to become a performer by exploiting their
weaknesses,
which it seems like now all the media has become all with his enemies,
have become,
can get them to take any position on any,
here's the perfect example.
Yeah.
For one year he's yelling at Elizabeth Warren,
take a DNA test,
take a DNA test.
She takes it in secret,
doesn't even test for native American blood.
It says she's at most 100024th she releases it and she goes,
Huh,
Mr President?
I took the test and you know what?
He goes,
who cares?
Yeah.
So now she's made a fool of,
he is not at all engaging with her and she's left.
You can even hear the curb,
your enthusiasm,
music playing as she talks,
and this moment has become a broken woman as a consequence of his clouding her
so thoroughly.
What is it about him that you think made him understand this?
How did this guy understand this psychological trick or whatever you want to
scenarios,
right?
Scott Adams,
who I know you've had on risk,
describes the Lucky Hitler phenomenon,
right?
That somehow it's just he always manages to say that what he needs to to upset
people.
The other scenario is like there's some kind of rain man thing going on that he
just sees people's weaknesses.
He knows exactly what to say and despite him themselves,
they lose their minds.
Another example of this was I think it was pixelated,
both.
There's some Twitter account and they made this fakes a screenshot from Michael
Wolfe's book fire and fury about how Trump watches TV all the time.
And the staff at the White House made something called the guerrilla channel.
And he talks to the gorillas on TV and he says,
oh,
that goodwill is good.
And people are,
and it was clearly a joke.
It was meant to be a joke.
People repeated this like,
oh my gosh,
Trump is so dumb.
He talks to television like,
wait a minute,
you can think he's as dumb as you want.
You're telling me this man who is 70 who's had a TV show,
doesn't understand that you can't talk to gorillas on a screen.
But that is the level that he's driven them to.
So it's hilarious to watch.
And it's beautiful from the [inaudible] perspective because he's diligent
organizing the political process and the presidency.
So the reverence that people have for the presidency has deadly consequences
because it allows them to get away with things like war.
And if you think the guy in the Oval Office is a clown and that clown is getting
ready to send your kids overseas to possibly die or possibly kill people,
you're going to be a lot more skeptical.
God,
there's a lock there.
So you think it's the whole book worth.
If only if only someone would write a book about this sort of thing.
There's a lot there.
So you think in an odd way,
his behavior is delegitimizing the presidency,
let's say the office of the presidency or more broadly government in general.
And you ultimately view that as a good thing because you don't think that really
has legitimate power to begin with.
Right.
One of the big views of the Murray Rothbard school is that the two political
parties are literally rival gangs.
And just like a gangster has the nice rings and the suits,
they wear their suits,
they go to the Senate.
But these are at base murderers who are plotting,
you know,
fighting with each other.
But it's in fighting.
Um,
so anytime the mask is dropped and you realize these people aren't stealing your
money,
they're trying to control your lives,
they're causing massive,
you know,
harm around the world often.
Uh,
that's a good thing.
What's the ratio element that comes out of all of this?
It's because for as much as I get a lot of this and I like a lot of the
trolling,
the good natured stuff that's really getting the,
the people that I don't like to flip their lids.
Like I love all that stuff.
And then there's this other piece of it that,
that strikes me as it's hard to tell it or they just intentionally inflammatory.
Do they really believe this?
What kind of power do these people have?
Are they coordinating all of that?
Yes.
Jared Taylor is the head race realist,
right?
These are the people who you racism as the most important issue,
the outright,
and I interviewed him for the,
for the book.
I went to his house and you know,
even he was confused and there's this great moment,
he's got this very weird accent.
He goes,
are you telling me these people really believe this Hitler stuff?
Like he couldn't wrap it and I go,
yeah.
And he goes,
the idea in this day and age that Hitlerism would be a model for America is
simply fantastic.
And I go,
you mean crazy,
right?
He goes,
Oh yes,
thank you for the clarification.
So even in that group though,
they're the racists,
but he is your approach.
You then you have the people who are full blown.
Yes.
Well what does that mean?
So there are the racist meaning there are just people who just full blown
racism.
They just actually racist.
They want people based on the color is going to have different laws or not be in
this country.
You are
correct.
And they say if you're not,
if you don't see that as the most important issue,
you're blind.
So I,
you know,
had to engage with that,
writing this book.
Then they're the ones who are,
everything's about the Jews,
the Jews,
you,
I was,
I was in Charlottesville.
I saw everything happening.
I couldn't go to all the events because my contact was told don't bring the Jew
to the party.
I was not wearing the blazer.
Uh,
but uh,
so there is this whole subculture and they disagree with themselves and it was
important for me to engage with them and express what their point of view is and
show how they're wrong.
Because what happens is when you drive people to the margin,
it's like telling an,
especially when deal with young males,
it's like when you tell kids if you smoke the principal,
your parents and everyone's going to get upset and then you can't get a pall
mall fast enough.
So that the same thing here,
it's like if you talk to these people and say certain things people you hate are
gonna get upset,
it's like,
sign me up.
So the point I make in this book is you take one red pill,
not the whole bottle.
Because once they realized that the corporate press is often dishonest and has
an agenda,
they fall down this rabbit hole.
And unless someone grabs him by the collar and said,
yeah,
you don't have to go all the way,
uh,
we,
we can stop right here.
Uh,
there are often lost.
So this is,
you would argue then the reason why sensoring these people in suspending people
on Twitter and booting people off Facebook and the rest of it is actually the
worst possible thing that you could do.
I don't know if you become,
you just feeding it,
I don't know if it's the worst,
but if they're going to say there is an elite agenda designed to drive us
underground and keep the truth from coming out,
now they have evidence.
Look,
we're being blocked.
They don't want to hear the truth.
So that is a,
and the fact that David Duke,
for example,
is still on Twitter,
is very curious to me.
And again,
with the Internet and technology.
So,
wait,
what do you think that's about then?
Well,
I think David Duke is a very useful foil for the left,
uh,
because when he endorses people at Keith Ellison or Johana Mar,
it's crickets,
right?
But when he says something positive about somebody else,
like,
oh my God,
David do about Trump.
Yeah.
I don't think he likes Trump too much cause Trump all Trump the kids married
except for one marriage Jews.
So,
you know,
I,
I it's,
it's uh,
he's not that fond of the president.
Uh,
everything's about Israel.
David Duke.
Um,
and I told him once on Twitter.
So that was a fun moment.
You took out the Duke,
like I don't know if I,
I know I did.
He's still there and that's the problem.
Like why is David Duke there while people like Laura Loomer art?
I think that is very odd,
uh,
um,
a situation.
And you would say that really is just because of the power dynamic within
Twitter or,
or within something bigger than,
I can't speak to why I'm not in the side.
Jack's mind Jack Dorsey's mind.
Yeah.
I do think there's something here that's not adding up and I think the more
transparency the better.
Uh,
and I think Jack and some level would agree with that.
Yeah.
What's your position on what to do with the tech companies at this point?
Related to all of this in the censorship and everything.
I think the solution is going to be just like back in the day we had cupid and
now you have Tinder and and,
and all these other sites and they separate out.
You're going,
there's no reason everyone has to be in one site.
So the more,
if Twitter wants to say we're a site for progressive ideas,
they have that right?
And,
and that's perfectly fine.
They're going to lose a huge market share because when you drive out fringe
ideas,
whether evil,
fringe,
you're also going to be driving out the good fringe idea.
That's where innovation happens.
So if you're going to have this bourgeois middle of the road,
I don't want weirdness,
uh,
you're going to lose the interesting people also.
So this is a very big double edged.
So then why hasn't this problem been fixed?
There's enough people frustrated with it all over the political map.
Good old classical liberals are just as frustrated as perhaps more nefarious
characters and nobody has solved
this.
But your frustration might be a feature because they say,
look,
we're obviously doing things right.
We've got Dave Ruben upset.
So if there,
uh,
if we live in a culture that's heavily dominated by the progressive ideology,
so for them,
if they are getting certain people upset,
they can say,
hey,
we're doing our job.
Right.
The euphemism they currently use as the quality of the conversation.
So yeah,
I mean this is the most Orwellian thing ever.
Like you are going to be judging quality.
So it's,
it's,
it's a very,
it's very,
and which is a very different thing from free speech,
which is messy and ugly and,
and,
and you know,
often reprehensible.
[inaudible].
How do you think that the new right then is supposed to,
I know you don't like boundaries and you don't like gate keeping in any of those
things,
but how do you think it anything,
I like gates.
I'm a,
I'm,
I'm not an inclusionist person.
I'm very much for freedom of association.
If I didn't want to talk to someone,
I'm not I black people liberally,
but how,
but all right,
so,
but you know,
in a wider group outside of just what's happening in your mind and your
interactions with people,
how do you think that this new sort of group of people that are all over the map
politically,
right?
Um,
how do they,
how do they keep the fringe people,
the truly bad people out of the way?
This seems to be the biggest
yes.
That nobody's solving.
Uh,
the Pr,
I don't think you can because technology has made,
it used to be you had three networks,
right?
ABC,
NBC,
CBS,
and between the three of them,
you get the news.
Then drudge came along.
I talking about in the book and the networks,
like he's a lot legitimate.
He's not legitimate.
He breaks one of the biggest stories of all Todd Monica Lewinsky.
They didn't know what to do.
He still,
he's not legitimate and illegitimate is like,
he broke news.
Who are you to say he's now Jim.
And so this,
this orthodox idea of legitimacy has no inherent meaning other than tribalism,
right?
So once you have technology and thanks to Twitter,
Facebook,
whatever,
everyone has their own Mike and there are more and more mikes being built every
day.
I don't see how you're going to be able to put that genie back in the bottle so
you just have to let it be.
Then you'd say there's just no option.
It's just is correct and you have to engage with bad ideas if you want to
diffuse them because you're not thanks to technology,
you're not going to be able to censor anyone.
Let me give you another example.
I have this in the book.
Let's suppose this is like 1990 right?
And you're having an argument censoring books and one guy like we need to censor
books like mine,
calm has bad consequence.
Someone else like,
no,
you need to hear free speech.
I come from 2019 teleport back in time and I say,
look,
someday you're going to be able to copy a book infinitely at no cost.
You press one button,
you send it anywhere on earth at the speed of light for free.
I would sound like a lunatic,
but that is the status quo.
Oh,
and also you could use a magic word.
No,
but orange and reader to password.
Oh,
okay.
Crazy person.
That's the status quo.
And technology is only going to increase more and more and more to empower the
individual at the expense of big conglomerates.
It becomes cheaper and cheaper to make your voice heard.
Back in the day.
You'd have to be like,
if you don't like it,
make your own network.
Well you did on now.
Now it's going to be,
I mean I've,
except we're still using their pipes.
I'm still dependent on,
at least for the moment on,
correct.
There's tech,
there's a great book called the goal.
And the point of this book is,
what's a goal there was to go for business and he says to make money.
So how you do this is you look at the pipeline from conception to production and
you look at what's slowing up your profits.
So maybe you don't have enough shipping boxes,
maybe you're not producing enough bottles,
maybe you have too much warehouse inventory.
So you've got gotta have more marketing.
Maybe youtube is not sending your videos out to your subscribers,
right?
So you look at what the issue is,
the bottleneck,
you fix that.
Once that's fixed,
there's to be another worst thing and you fix that.
So Twitter in many ways is a rear guard movement right now because people are
realizing it's paypal and it's the banks that,
and it's the fact that there's domain registrars,
those are the next three that people are going to build alternatives to.
Cause that's where the banks are shutting down accounts right now.
And that's what's being underreported.
So Twitter is kind of a little bit of a distraction because you'll always be
able to make some rival to Twitter,
banking and paypal.
That's what something people have to look at now.
And do you think the right people are looking at it,
uh,
I think in your world or are people looking at it?
I don't think this is an ideological thing.
I think it's just some entrepreneur who sees a market opportunity to be like,
paypal is being arbitrary and I can compete with them on some level.
All it takes is that one guy and then the battle was won and then it's going to
be another battle.
It's a as some situation.
So what are some of the policies of the new,
if the new right becomes,
takes over the conservative movement or take,
so let's try the consent decree.
The enemy,
right?
So whatever that is,
that whether they burn the thing down or where they,
whether they infiltrate it or whatever,
the people that care about these ideas broadly that you're talking about,
what does it actually look like politically?
Like what are the things that they would be fighting for police?
And this is what's hilarious is you have a group who's United only by their
oppositions.
Progressivism.
What do you want to do?
They have no even close to unanimity.
Someone UN,
military juntas like just martial law.
Some like me,
not for me.
Not For me.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right,
good.
Uh,
someone,
a complete liberty meaning anarchy.
Uh,
somewhat.
Um,
a restriction of the right to vote.
Uh,
some want to accelerate,
they want more leftism cause they think if you accelerate and amplify the system
is going to collapse because the inherent contradictions and leftism so you have
no consensus whatsoever about what the next steps and same thing with like for
example,
they think people think,
oh everyone in this group likes Trump.
Some of them are loath Trump completely and,
and unabashedly and culture who I've talked about in this book,
she's come out very hard against him and I think she called him a moron or
something like that.
What do you make of her related to Trump?
It was like she was huge pro Trump,
but then he's not,
you know,
he's not building the wall fast enough for her or a couple of the other things.
It's like,
so you still also some real politic involved.
Yeah.
Culture used to be a real troll.
Right.
She knew how to say the exact right things to upset people.
Now she's gotten much more serious and ideological in her later books.
It's interesting to see her relationship with Trump.
I mean,
she said at one point she thought America was like 90%,
no chance.
Now it's maybe 40% because of Trump's election.
Uh,
she's very 90% are trans.
What that America's done,
we're done.
She thought it was like we're over 90% chance.
And then she was like,
okay,
maybe it's 40% that were done because Trump got elected.
Um,
I can't really speak for her,
but she is a very kind of a interesting character.
And I discuss your ideas at length cause her book,
Adios America was probably the most influential book of the 2016 Election Cycle.
That's the book where Trump got the idea of they're sending the rapists.
Uh,
who do you find you can debate with on the other side of this?
So I get you can,
you can be around people on the right that you disagree on a lot of these
different things and you don't come out of the racist camp and all that stuff.
You find that there are some good actors on the left that you can engage with.
Oh,
I a lot.
Uh,
people like,
uh,
Glenn Greenwald,
Michael Tracy,
Jimmy door.
Um,
I actually don't debate cause I'm not interested in persuasion.
I'm just there to have fun.
Uh,
and I think debating is often a waste of time and it's always a waste of time.
I mean the cost benefits.
So I don't really do,
I've had a few people on my show who are,
you know,
pretty far left.
No Mickey constant was on a,
I also,
you'd like debating with conservatives.
Um,
cause I really disagree with them and since I'm coming at them from this center
line on that conservatism is separatism.
Is progressivism driving the speed limit?
So,
uh,
one of the things I discuss in this book is National Review.
My favorite Paleontology magazine in the late nineties,
they had this,
uh,
editorial comparing the fight for gay rights to a theoretical Pfeiffer
necrophilia and saying,
what's the difference between fighting for two men to have sex with each other
as opposed to having sex with a corpse?
And it was just a very disturbing article.
But now the conservative case for gay marriage.
So what principals are there that would have you say that then and have you say
this now.
So it's disturbing then.
And the a hypocrisy is disturbing,
uh,
to this day as well.
So you're,
you're more,
you care more about the hypocrisy of it,
not the,
you don't care about gay marriage.
Well,
I,
I mean I care about both.
I mean,
if you're going to have a principal,
I would have more respect for someone to be like gay marriage is wrong because
of the Bible,
blah,
Blah Blah and stick to that as opposed to I'm anti gay then cause I'm a phony
and now Mancy gay now cause I'm a phony.
You're,
you're bringing nothing to the table.
Yeah.
But I mean you protect you specifically.
You don't care.
I do.
I wouldn't want,
I don't care.
I'm glad that you're married to that too.
Well that's what I meant.
I mean,
you don't care.
Uh,
see,
I mean Karen and negative sense.
Oh of course.
No,
no.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
Please Mary.
Whatever you want.
Yeah.
Mary a corpse.
And we'll know.
Well,
you do have limits only if they're good to like only if they're good,
then you can marry a quarter.
Yeah.
Um,
how crazy do you think things are going to get as we roll into 2020 because I
think we're still as crazy as possible
fully.
And here's something that I,
I've called that once I say no one can really kind of deny it.
A historically the president or the nominee hasn't really engaged with the other
party's primary process.
For the first time in history,
a sitting president is going to be live tweeting the debates and the primary of
the other team.
And not only that,
it's not like he's gonna accommodate like,
Oh,
I disagree with his economic plan.
He's loving nukes in his Trump Ian style.
And none of these 23 candidates are good to know what to do.
And none of their advisors who are getting paid a lot of money,
social media experts are going to have know what to do.
There's no blueprint.
And the question becomes,
is it a badge of honor that Trump is clowning me?
Does that make me the strong candidate?
Do I ignore him?
Am I above the fray?
Like historical people used to do like,
oh my opponent,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
So this is going to be absolutely hilarious.
And you want that hilarity.
The more chaos,
the better politically.
Yeah.
I don't want people to be able to get together and impose their will.
So what if you were one of the 23?
What would you do
as someone that knows how to play the trolling game that knows how to,
you know,
throw the bombs back,
let's say,
what would you do?
Oh,
Trump.
So you're onstage trumps,
you know,
do it is Twitter thing.
You get off stage,
you see what's going on,
what would you do or what would you tell if you were an advisor to one of these
people,
what would you do?
Oh,
well,
I,
I know you don't want to give away all your have designed,
I would never advise it.
In all seriousness.
A,
what I would do is if you look at when he was,
uh,
a comedy central roast,
and they ask them beforehand,
they said,
what jokes can you make and can you make?
The only thing he wasn't comfortable being joked about was that he's not as rich
as he wanted as he claims he is.
So since that's his line,
I would hit him with that line as much as possible.
But at the same time it's hard to someone who is that,
you know,
Hiroshima in a China shop.
I mean he's,
he's,
he's like,
it is,
but I don't,
Justin Amash got him pretty good I think over the weekend with coming out in
favor of impeachment.
I think that really ruffled this and others were on the,
oh no,
you know what it is.
This is what I would hit him with.
I would say you bragged during the campaign that you had hired the best and
smartest people.
How come all these people are resigning,
you know,
and,
and hit him with that.
His big core competency,
alleged core competency.
How competent do you think he is or isn't a,
I actually forgetting the tactic,
the trolling tactic,
Twitter as competent as being president,
but as being frozen.
It's hard to tell because there's,
I've that theory that probably isn't that crazy that when you'd become president
they sit you down and they're like,
all right,
this is what you can do and this is what you can't do.
The fact that Obama was droning everyone all the time,
it seems like it's out of his,
you know,
peacenik background or it could be that,
he was a closet,
you know,
Hawk the whole time.
We don't know.
I don't think any of us really know what it's like to be president.
The fact that he hasn't gotten a lot of his big promises through is kind of a
big deal.
The fact that he has taken on unprecedented opposition and his head is still,
you know,
being held hide.
His approval ratings are still relatively high.
I mean that's a bit of an accomplishment.
So since you wrote a book on North Korea.
Yeah.
And there's been a little,
I think last time I had you on,
maybe they were in the beginnings of some shows,
discussions.
Where are we at with North Korea right now?
I am.
So North Korea has this a secret weapon which causes everyone on earth to have
amnesia.
And what happens is North Korea goes through these cycles as night follows day,
which is there'll be warmongers,
we're going to nuke America,
we're going to kill everyone,
blah,
blah.
And then six months later we want peace.
Please work with us,
please work with us.
And they've just gone back to the war cycle and everyone's like,
oh my God,
we've never heard this for North Korea had PR sentence president Trump to death.
Uh,
they were threatening to new Guam and Alaska and even previously that they were
thrown into new Boston.
So it's,
this is how they,
this is their song.
Terrible.
Oh,
come on now.
It's um,
so this is where they are right now.
I am very hopeful.
The thing I'm very happy with with president Trump is that North Korea is now on
the front pages because we need to engage with this most evil country.
And I was on Fox and friends first or a while ago and they said,
what is your big concern with the summit?
And I said the continuing slavery of the North Korean people.
So that whenever you're looking at this issue,
always ask,
in my view,
what does this mean for these 20 million hostages who are being kept enslaved by
this evil government that starved it's population on purpose during the 90s and
killed one to 2 million people.
That's is not funny.
So do you think that Trump is sort of the perfect person for this,
that as North Korea vacillates back and forth with all this rhetoric that Trump
can actually match them at that?
And that might be the thing that kind of allows a detente.
I don't know about perfect,
but I,
you have to have hope for these people especially,
I mean not to sound whatever.
Once you've been there and you've seen people there.
Everyone I met in North Korea is still there.
Like every single person I saw on the street,
every kid,
every grandma.
And it messes with your head because this is what,
2012 they come up.
Your life has changed since 22 I'll think of much mine has and none of theirs
has.
I still see my guide,
you know,
pictures of her on Instagram and she's still trapped and she like a million are
there,
but she's still trapped in that prison with those gilded bars.
So it's very disturbing.
How does an anarchist care about foreign policy?
Well,
because this,
the governments,
the enemy,
this is the most evil government on earth.
This is a pretty uh,
easy syllogism.
Okay,
interesting.
You don't really think about that though.
I mean generally when people think of a more libertarian view of the world,
it's like,
no,
just let everybody do whatever the hell
they want.
Well,
I'm not going to let the government do whatever the hell they wanted these
people.
Yeah,
I mean,
and that's the other thing,
like we have it.
So,
even though it's not your government,
these are human beings and you know,
being born in the Soviet Union,
being Jewish,
these were two chances my family could have been sent to concentration camp.
So the fact that we have concentration camps right now,
that you could see them on Google earth,
you know what,
not at high school,
I always talk about how the Holocaust happened,
how the hell has happened.
Something similar happened in the 90s in North Korea against its own population.
So this is something that maybe other people don't care.
But for me it's kind of like there,
but for the grace of God,
go I,
and when I met the guy that I had,
she had the same haircut my mom had in like 1982 which is a cutting edge in
North Korea,
but it's just looking at like a sliding doors thing and it's like,
holy crap,
I could have been born here.
And instead of sitting here in my Willy Wonka costume,
you know,
who knows what would've happened to me.
What do you think's going to happen to the traditional conservatives?
Oh God,
I is it absolutely over because they can't withstand what's coming on both
sides at this point.
I don't see how they come back because I don't,
they didn't bring that much to the table to begin with as opposed to like give
socking to the left and now Trump is talking to the left more than anyone else
has.
I'm going to be talking to Ben domination,
you know,
not that long from the federalists.
And I'm very curious to hear his take on this book and this thesis because it
could because he's someone that is more of a traditional hardcore,
pure conservative.
Yeah.
Mutual respect.
I like him a lot.
Um,
but I don't see how they regain,
uh,
this party especially because if one of the big issues with conservatism and
maybe republicanism is young people,
young people are going to be drawn to humor and edginess and memes and they're
not going to be drawn to kind of like a,
Hey,
remember Reagan,
you know,
Reagan's great,
he ended the Cold War,
but this is not going to be a selling point for your movement.
And also the,
I think young people are also drawn to aggression,
um,
and kind of flipping over tables and that's what the new right does offer them.
Are there political leaders outside of however much Trump is involved in this?
Are there some other people that you like?
I know that's the weird thing.
It's like you don't want a political leader per se because you don't want to be
personally who I like.
Yeah.
Well or that you think can
sort of grab some of these pieces and do something good in your estimation.
Uh,
I can't,
I,
I'm sure there are.
Telsey Gabbert I like anyone who brings more of the antiwar message.
Uh,
funny you wrote a book called the New Right,
and you're picking a candidate who was running as a democrat.
Sure.
Anti War Democrat,
but I,
interesting.
I would love it if there was a complete consensus in Washington that war is a
last resort and an absolute nightmare.
That is my goal.
So I just like,
we agree that slavery is a nonstarter.
The like,
sure,
I'll get the argument that maybe we have to go to war,
but the fact that we can be so glib about it and be like,
oh yeah,
we're just gonna [inaudible] here's another example.
Do you think that we've crossed a little bit of a threshold when it comes to
war?
I mean,
I feel like the mistakes of Iraq and nobody knows why the hell we're in
Afghanistan still Trump is not beating wardrobes.
You know,
there's,
there's stuff about,
there's always this over the top rhetoric related to Iran,
but I,
I don't sense,
this is a guy that wants to just say,
I think he's actually very against the blog,
these nation building and the blood lust of the establishment,
which I include.
The corporate press cannot be overstated.
Uh,
when 2016 Trump's the nominee,
we heard it every single day.
He's crazy.
He's going to give us to world war three.
He's going to get pissed off at a tweet from China and press the nuclear button.
Remember,
we heard this all the time.
Carly fury and I got asked this the second debate.
The first question,
do you trust president Trump with his finger on the nuclear button and now,
uh,
China has hacked our systems.
Russia has tried to interfere with our elections and the press is constantly
saying,
do something about it.
Do something about,
do something.
I'd do something about Venezuela.
So the fact that he's not getting us into world war three is not being used as a
slight against him by the same people who regarded that as a problem when he was
a nominee.
It's horrific.
And this has been a long time coming.
How much does it since uh,
the,
we talked about yellow journalism in high school.
I remember,
uh,
the Spanish American war and then they pretend they went away.
It didn't go away.
The same press wants,
if it bleeds,
it leads.
They can't wait to get us into another engagement.
It's,
it's disgraceful what happened.
What has to happen with the press then?
And I mean this in terms of cable news,
mainstream news,
Network News,
I mean this vox Huffpo sure.
The battle is the battle is won when the average corporate journalist is
regarded with the exact same way as the average tobacco executive.
They have a job.
Uh,
they're promoting their product.
Their product is cancerous and deadly.
They're often bright people.
They're often good people,
but be aware of what it is that they're selling you.
So how do we find some people to trust in the mix of all of this in this big
mess?
Uh,
trust,
but verify.
I mean,
I'll use the Reagan.
I mean trust is,
I'm not interested in trusting people initially in,
in a trusting ideas and creating mechanisms that people can't enforce their
wills.
The trust won't be necessary.
Like I don't need to trust like Ebay,
right?
I don't need to trust that other guy is going to be a honorable because they're,
they're different systems.
I can get my money refunded,
so and so forth.
So there's no reason for me to have a political trust because systemically he's
going to betray me at some point or another.
God,
there's a lot here at malice.
Thank you.
Take me somewhere else altogether.
W what do you mean?
Where else do you want to go in this conversation right now?
Oh,
well I got,
I mean,
I've got a million things rattling here.
[inaudible] your humerus.
Yeah.
Doesn't it bother you?
I,
one of the things I defend in this book is dark humor.
And here's the let's tie back to North Korea.
Yeah.
I knew a refugee and he said,
so when people say that's not funny,
right?
Uh,
it's this puritanism HL Mencken said,
puritanism is the idea that someone somewhere is happy.
Right?
I knew this refugee North Korean refugee and he went to high school here and
he's talking to his friends and they go,
hey,
remember when we were kids we had Pokemon?
And he goes,
yeah,
except instead of Pokemon and watch my dad's starved to death.
Now are you going to tell him that's not appropriate?
Right,
right.
Are you,
do you know what it's like to,
what is his coping mechanisms?
Do you know what it's like to watch someone's hungry,
starve to death,
and it's your own dad?
We can never wrap our heads around this.
So for you to tell him that kind of joke is not appropriate.
How dare you buying McFarland?
A great comedian was roasting Jim Norton and she said,
your show is so and listen to bubble.
I'd rather hear my daughter drown.
Now that's very dark,
but are you telling me she doesn't love her daughter?
Are you telling me she doesn't know how to tell a joke?
So the metaphor I use when people say a certain subject is not appropriate for
humor.
I say it's like flour Flou F l o U R is flower food.
Well no one eats flour,
but everyone eats it when it's processed and baked.
Right?
So same thing with jokes then.
This darker the subject,
the harder it is to make it palatable.
And I've examples of,
you know,
they made me cut one joke,
but I have examples of all sorts of,
you know,
subjects that are supposed to be off limits.
And maybe you personally don't find it funny if someone's been assaulted and
they're like,
you know,
these kinds of jokes set me off.
That's there.
But the idea that no one,
yeah,
she'd find that funny,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Well it's also stealing something that's very human is that we use humorous
comedy is tragedy plus time.
We use humor to be able to look back on the past.
I mean if Mel Brooks couldn't of made fun of Hitler,
couldn't of made fun of the Holocaust,
that was,
that was actually healing for,
I'm sure for him personally,
but for millions of other people,
but the establishment which gets by on legitimacy and quality conversation,
it cannot abide that court jester laughing at them
is,
do you think that's why they took out the AOC parody on on Twitter because it
was really freaking good.
Okay.
They took out a lot of parody accounts and it's strange.
All those Trump parody accounts are still up and the pair and sign live,
which is their right and their great do it make the,
you should be making on the president,
but you're not saying it's great Ruo but why not?
Sure.
Pretty crappy.
I haven't watched it in a way.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
I haven't watched it in 15 years,
but every time I see a ten second clip,
it's like,
it's basically,
it's basically as good as the gene wilder Willy Wonka movie.
So that's a call back,
my friend.
Yeah,
I understood it was a call back.
The most ludicrous thing I've ever heard in my entire life.
Someone who I love your outside the box thinking and yet
it's bizarre.
The point is,
uh,
humor is,
if it's this,
it's a Jewish thing.
It's this Jewish thing of laughing to keep from crying.
And it's a very waspy thing,
you know,
it's like,
ah,
you know,
you don't make the kind of jokes there table.
And just because something isn't for someone doesn't mean it's not for no one.
And one of the elements of the evangelical left is the idea of universalism.
Everything has to be inclusive,
everything has to be for everyone.
And my answer is no,
not everything has to be for everyone.
And that's okay.
Not everyone is welcomed my house,
not everyone's gonna enjoy this book.
And you know what?
If you don't think I'm interesting or funny or smart,
I wish you nothing but goodwill,
this a big world,
go live your best life.
Do you think that it doesn't make sense or does it deeply that they're obsessed
with our differences?
They're obsessed with our skin color differences in our sexuality and our gender
difference.
That does.
I mean that is the entire thrust of everything that they're giving us.
And yet they're also the ones that want us to be exactly the same.
Uh,
well I is that because,
is that a feature or a bug?
Actually,
I don't know if it's a feature or a bug.
It certainly works for them to some extent because what,
you know,
kind of evangelical and,
and gives people is a sense of certainty and it also gives them a sense of being
saved.
Right?
So once I recognize the pervasiveness of wreck of racism,
I've Kinda been initiated into the mysteries of this faith.
And therefore,
since I'm inherently good,
now I'm in a position to condemn heretics and centers and if necessary,
wipe them off the face of the earth.
So they,
they want us to be the same in terms of being saved,
but they don't want us to be necessarily saving in terms of a literalist.
I don't know that I've ever heard you talk about this specifically,
but how much of what you think is going on with the evangelical left,
as you just described them,
is just a disconnect from faith?
Oh,
I think it's a degeneration of the Social Gospel.
So I traced this so conservatives,
you know when I talk to them,
they're like,
oh,
they admit that the left controls culture and media and Hollywood and things and
things like that,
and you say,
well,
how did this happen?
And they're like,
we have to have our own version and go,
how did this happen?
They're like,
oh,
it used to be,
I'm like,
when?
When it was the 1930s when literal communists were running Hollywood,
when Woodrow Wilson is playing birth of a nation at the White House,
FDR has so many Democrats that they have to sit on the republican side of the
seats in Congress.
It makes no sense.
Other than that you're saying it's not that they lost control,
they never had control.
Correct.
It's always been,
and there's a reason because leftism lends itself to innovation and creativity
because one of the aspects of leftism is liking what's new,
liking what's innovative,
this psychological thing.
And there's nothing wrong with being conservative saying I don't like new stuff.
I like things to saying that's if that's fine for you,
but that's going to be a huge disadvantage when you're trying to attract people
who are artistically minded because they're going to be drawn to those who are
maybe not overly openly minded.
Right,
because it sounds good.
I'm for progress.
Everyone's for progress,
but it depends what you're progressing to.
Correct.
Right.
Is the rub.
So how conservatives,
how low the left controls culture and built it is one of the big themes of this
book and I think filling in a big hole on the right because conservatives really
don't know.
And here's another example,
concerns.
You remember our,
sure back in the nineties Jon Stewart,
you know,
what are the 2000 excuse me was running the show.
And the answer was let's have a conservative daily show.
That's not creativity,
that's just mirroring what someone else has built as opposed to people like I
would say like rush Limbaugh and Roger Ailes,
rush Limbaugh invented basically talk radio made or what it was.
Roger Ailes was told,
we want you to compete with CNN.
He goes,
no,
no.
I'm going to destroy CNN.
And CNN was all news and he made it this news entertainment opinion thing and
then CNN followed suit.
So those are two examples of the right actually creating something,
a kind of city generis you think we ever get to something that feels a little
more stable.
Again,
I don't work at right now I think stability politically means oppression.
And I think the stability of like,
let's suppose the fifties and this is one thing that I'm hopeful with social
media,
they were entire schools of thought.
They were made invisible because they were threatening to the social order and
now they have to pick people off one by one instead of entire schools of
thought.
And that is progress in a good way.
What if you were picked off?
I'm too charming and I know I,
I mean I,
I can be Glib suck.
It would suck.
I mean what would you do?
I mean because I know what a lot of people are thinking.
It's like,
you know,
we've seen enough of the names that we've mentioned throughout this shirt get
picked off and get suspended and get banned.
It's not that there are best buddies or anything,
but there were everyone's sort of in the same sort of circles at some level.
Uh,
again,
coming from that Soviet background,
I know that idea of like it could be you tomorrow,
it's not.
It's always at random cause that way you keep everyone's scared to dive into
that a little bit more.
Sure.
So one of the techniques that the Soviets did is it wouldn't be like the worst
people who would get kicked off like a barrier said,
find me the man.
I'll find you the crime.
So style and I do not think we're in a Stalinist society.
I'm just using this as a metaphor,
a very loose metaphor.
I just really want that to be clear cause I,
we got a ways to go before that.
But the,
the principal to keep a population kind of submissive is,
it's not always the loud mouth.
You pick the housewife or you pick this grandma and then everyone knows you
could be next.
So you only got to take out like three people and that 100 are going up
basically fall in line.
And because Twitter's rules are ambiguous and it's seemingly at random and they
don't even give warning,
they could've sat down that AOC account and said these three tweets are
offensive.
Delete them.
Yeah.
There.
So even though he did nothing wrong by the,
by the rules that they supposedly put out there,
I mean he labeled it as a parody account.
That's the main thing.
Sure.
And many people have more than one account and very,
and also if you're want to be,
have this kind of public square,
you know,
political conversation.
Once someone is a certain level of stature who are,
you know,
kind of an influencer,
it might be that Jack has to talk to them personally or there has to be three
checks before their band.
Or You could have warnings.
I mean there's a lot of systems for keeping people who are part of this thriving
conversation in place,
but that's not what they want and that's their right.
But this is something that people should recognize.
So you would say that the tech companies basically want to keep us all in semi
darkness all the time because that's the easiest way to,
I don't know if it's easy,
but it seems to be effective for them in of cause then you have self censorship.
Right.
Because you know,
I had this tweet,
I don't even remember what it was and I was scared to put it up because I'm like
at any moment that eye of Sauron can fall on me and on booted.
Yeah.
And I'm sure you know this feeling very well.
So that's with your youtube stuff?
No,
I know it extremely well and it's like if I'm even remotely close to where the
cliff is,
man,
things have shifted in a seriously dangerous way.
There will be a certain amount of people that don't want me talking to you.
There are certain amount of people that didn't want to be talking to,
to Cernovich,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And I have to figure out who is who.
I think it's okay to talk about.
Let's talk about that in the book.
How is it okay for Barbara Walters to sit down with like Kadafi who murdered so
many people?
Uh,
Diane Sawyer with Charles Manson,
I mean with a swastika on his forehead that telling me the Diane Sawyer didn't
endorse all the views of Charles Manson because that seems to be what they say
about if I sit down with somebody I must endorse older boy.
It's amazing.
And when they're like,
oh,
he follows this person on Twitter,
it's like everyone follows the precedent and he's the for it.
Like when CNN places video his speech,
does that mean they're,
they're endorsing it.
So it's a very weird situation.
But again,
because they're legitimate,
you're unorthodox.
You're not legitimate.
You don't have the same rights in a sense that they do.
Well,
we talk about it right before we started,
but you saw the way media,
uh,
media matters went after me cause I was going to have mayor Pete on and
immediately went ahead of him though.
Yeah.
Well,
so that's the thing.
Yeah.
Well,
can you take that away?
I mean you,
you know exactly how it works.
Like they can't,
like when Donald Trump Jr,
uh,
took a tweet of mine and put on Instagram and for days I was sending people off.
Basically it was like,
well,
they can't get a Trump so they're going to get at me.
So if they can,
so you don't give a crap about media matters,
I'm sure.
But they can sure get to Pete because they'll have his ear and it worked
apparently.
I mean,
think how sad and depressing that is.
Forget,
forget mayor Pete coming in here and doing the show.
It's actually irrelevant.
I would like to have talk to the guy,
but that strikes me is irrelevant.
It's more that either he or his handlers are willing to bow to the mob that he,
he,
you know,
his people basically agree to do an interview.
And then because media matters Huffpo and box,
which the latter two are supposed to be places of journalism,
they are leveraging,
uh,
or trying to influence a political candidate from talking to,
the only reason a mayor of Indiana town is in the running for the presidency is
because of Huffpo media matters.
And Vox,
the I,
the idea of this,
a platform for even Senate beggars belief.
So of course he's going to cow tow to the people who put them in the position.
He has this guy's known natural constituencies like 37 years old.
We've got a big battle ahead of us.
Yeah.
And the important thing is,
uh,
to have fun and enjoy life because we're still free and we're still blessed in
this country.
And this is one that things I do disagree with,
with many POCs than you.
Right.
These people think America's ruined were destroyed.
There's no hope.
And it makes me very,
very sad because you go online and then you find more creative people doing
awesome things,
then you can count.
Yeah.
And we definitely focus,
seemingly we focus on the negative more,
but that is one of the things that when I see you on Twitter and I'm like,
you are actually having fun with this and there is a need.
This endless political politicy politicization.
Yes.
Did I say that?
Yes,
you did.
Yeah.
Of everything.
It's making people crazy and depressed.
Uh,
one of the things I really hate about the left and a certain kind of the left is
the idea that the personal is the political.
And to me,
if I disagree with someone politically that this would have any ramification on
our friendship is so profoundly disturbing.
I can't even begin the like if God forbid,
some of my family dies and I have to look at my phone and be like,
well I can't call this person because they're a Bernie person.
What kind of human twisted,
twisted place.
And even people who are like regular Christians don't think in these terms.
Like,
I have good friends.
I'm staying with a couple there.
They're all solid Christians.
If my mom,
something happened,
my family,
one of theirs,
I mean,
you're Jewish.
This would never even enter their heads.
And not even in a million years.
But it's like,
oh,
you're a Trump voter.
You're a Hillary voter.
I can't,
you know,
whatever.
With you,
this is very,
very tribal and disturbing to me.
Have you figured out any ways to deprogram some of these people?
Yes.
A humor.
Um,
I think it's,
I think once you,
I encourage people to see the absurdity of their position and also it's tell
them you can let go.
You don't have to be so ideological all the time.
Life is wonderful.
Enjoy your life and you shouldn't be depressed.
Let's suppose,
let's suppose Mike Pence,
if you're gay and Mike Prince is precedent that might suck for you.
But come on,
go to what you go.
Do we whoa,
go to hamburger Mary's.
Have Fun.
I mean,
this is not really a reflection of your life because there will always be a
precedent that you hate.
So focus as much as you can.
And this isn't to be shocking.
Message on living your life to the fullest.
That's it,
man.
Yeah.
I don't need to ask you anything else.
That's it.
I think let's get people,
regardless of where the politics fall on any of this,
it's like,
let's get people to realize it's still pretty good and,
and don't get too caught up in all the literacy and just when I'm trolling
someone,
just retweet it and sit back and laugh.
Don't on my trolls.
Where do you get this jacket?
Uh,
I mean,
I know Beluga made it
follow the Willy Wonka of politics.
Michael Malice on the Twitter at Michael Malice.
[inaudible].